[Music]
Hey everyone. Where we last left off, I
showed what linear transformations look
like and how to represent them using
matrices.
This is worth a quick recap because it's
just really important. But of course, if
this feels like more than just a recap,
go back and watch the full video.
Technically speaking, linear
transformations are functions with
vectors as inputs and vectors as
outputs. But I showed last time how we
can think about them visually as
smooshing around space in such a way
that grid lines stay parallel and evenly
spaced and so that the origin remains
fixed.
The key takeaway was that a linear
transformation is completely determined
by where it takes the basis vectors of
the space, which for two dimensions
means I hat and J hat.
This is because any other vector can be
described as a linear combination of
those basis vectors. A vector with
coordinates XY is X * I hat + Y * J hat.
After going through the transformation,
this property that grid lines remain
parallel and evenly spaced has a
wonderful consequence. The place where
your vector lands will be X times the
transformed version of I hat + Y times
the transformed version of J hat.
This means if you keep a record of the
coordinates where I hat lands and the
coordinates where J hat lands, you can
compute that a vector which starts at XY
must land on X times the new coordinates
of I hat + Y times the new coordinates
of J hat.
The convention is to record the
coordinates of where I hat and J hat
land as the columns of a matrix and to
define this sum of the scaled versions
of those columns by X and Y to be matrix
vector multiplication.
In this way, a matrix represents a
specific linear transformation and
multiplying a matrix by a vector is what
it means computationally to apply that
transformation to that vector.
All right, recap over. On to the new
stuff.
Oftentimes, you find yourself wanting to
describe the effects of applying one
transformation and then another. For
example, maybe you want to describe what
happens when you first rotate the plane
90° counterclockwise, then apply a
shear.
The overall effect here, from start to
finish, is another linear transformation
distinct from the rotation and the
shear.
This new linear transformation is
commonly called the composition of the
two separate transformations we applied.
And like any linear transformation, it
can be described with a matrix all of
its own by following I hat and J hat.
In this example, the ultimate landing
spot for I hat after both
transformations is 1 1. So let's make
that the first column of a matrix.
Likewise, J hat ultimately ends up at
the location -1 0. So we make that the
second column of the matrix.
This new matrix captures the overall
effect of applying a rotation then a
shear, but as one single action rather
than two successive ones.
Here's one way to think about that new
matrix. If you were to take some vector
and pump it through the rotation then
the shear, the long way to compute where
it ends up is to first multiply it on
the left by the rotation matrix. Then
take whatever you get and multiply that
on the left by the shear matrix. This
is, numerically speaking, what it means
to apply a rotation then a shear to a
given vector.
But whatever you get should be the same
as just applying this new composition
matrix that we just found by that same
vector, no matter what vector you chose,
since this new matrix is supposed to
capture the same overall effect as the
rotation then shear action.
Based on how things are written down
here, I think it's reasonable to call
this new matrix the product of the
original two matrices. Don't you?
We can think about how to compute that
product more generally in just a moment,
but it's way too easy to get lost in the
forest of numbers. Always remember that
multiplying two matrices like this has
the geometric meaning of applying one
transformation then another.
One thing that's kind of weird here is
that this has us reading from right to
left. You first apply the transformation
represented by the matrix on the right,
then you apply the transformation
represented by the matrix on the left.
This stems from function notation, since
we write functions on the left of
variables, so every time you compose two
functions, you always have to read it
right to left. Good news for the Hebrew
readers, bad news for the rest of us.
Let's look at another example.
Take the matrix with columns 1 1 and -2
0, whose transformation looks like this.
And let's call it M1.
Next, take the matrix with columns 0 1
and 2 0, whose transformation looks like
this.
And let's call that guy M2.
The total effect of applying M1 then M2
gives us a new transformation. So let's
find its matrix. But this time, let's
see if we can do it without watching the
animations and instead just using the
numerical entries in each matrix.
First, we need to figure out where I hat
goes.
After applying M1, the new coordinates
of I hat, by definition, are given by
that first column of M1, namely 1 1.
To see what happens after applying M2,
multiply the matrix for M2 by that
vector 1 1.
Working it out the way that I described
last video, you'll get the vector 2 1.
This will be the first column of the
composition matrix.
Likewise, to follow J hat, the second
column of M1 tells us that it first
lands on -2 0.
Then, when we apply M2 to that vector,
you can work out the matrix vector
product to get 0 -2,
which becomes the second column of our
composition matrix.
Let me talk through that same process
again, but this time I'll show variable
entries in each matrix just to show that
the same line of reasoning works for any
matrices. This is more symbol-heavy and
will require some more room, but it
should be pretty satisfying for anyone
who has previously been taught matrix
multiplication the more rote way.
To follow where I hat goes, start by
looking at the first column of the
matrix on the right, since this is where
I hat initially lands.
Multiplying that column by the matrix on
the left is how you can tell where the
intermediate version of I hat ends up
after applying the second
transformation.
So the first column of the composition
matrix will always equal the left matrix
times the first column of the right
matrix.
Likewise, J hat will always initially
land on the second column of the right
matrix.
So multiplying the left matrix by this
second column will give its final
location and hence that's the second
column of the composition matrix.
Notice, there's a lot of symbols here
and it's common to be taught this
formula as something to memorize along
with a certain algorithmic process to
kind of help remember it. But I really
do think that before memorizing that
process, you should get in the habit of
thinking about what matrix
multiplication really represents,
applying one transformation after
another.
Trust me, this will give you a much
better conceptual framework that makes
the properties of matrix multiplication
much easier to understand.
For example, here's a question. Does it
matter what order we put the two
matrices in when we multiply them?
Well, let's think through a simple
example like the one from earlier. Take
a shear which fixes I hat and smooshes J
hat over to the right and a 90°
rotation.
If you first do the shear then rotate,
we can see that I hat ends up at 0 1 and
J hat ends up at -1 1. Both are
generally pointing close together.
If you first rotate then do the shear,
I hat ends up over at 1 1 and J hat is
often a different direction at -1 0 and
they're pointing, you know, farther
apart.
The overall effect here is clearly
different, so evidently order totally
does matter.
Notice, by thinking in terms of
transformations, that's the kind of
thing that you can do in your head by
visualizing. No matrix multiplication
necessary.
I remember when I first took linear
algebra, there was this one homework
problem that asked us to prove that
matrix multiplication is associative.
This means that if you have three
matrices A, B, and C and you multiply
them all together, it shouldn't matter
if you first compute A * B then multiply
the result by C, or if you first
multiply B * C then multiply that result
by A on the left. In other words, it
doesn't matter where you put the
parentheses.
Now, if you try to work through this
numerically like I did back then, it's
horrible, just horrible and
unenlightening for that matter. But when
you think about matrix multiplication as
applying one transformation after
another, this property is just trivial.
Can you see why?
What it's saying is that if you first
apply C then B then A, it's the same as
applying C then B then A.
I mean, there's nothing to prove. You're
just applying the same three things one
after the other, all in the same order.
This might feel like cheating, but it's
not. This is an honest-to-goodness proof
that matrix multiplication is
associative. And even better than that,
it's a good explanation for why that
property should be true.
I really do encourage you to play around
more with this idea, imagining two
different transformations, thinking
about what happens when you apply one
after the other, and then working out
the matrix product numerically. Trust
me, this is the kind of playtime that
really makes the idea sink in.
In the next video, I'll start talking
about extending these ideas beyond just
two dimensions. See you then.
[Music]
I